[Music]
well hello reject nation
I'm Greg Alva misconception Oh
transition 10 misconceptions about the
female body from all time tens I have a
selection of videos to choose from with
the time I have cat available here I
went through all the videos this one she
saw and went oh let's do that one and
that's the story let's see if this is
actually I all know misconception only
men have Adam's apples really the truth
women have them too they just don't show
quite as much also known as their
laryngeal prominence the Adam's apple is
the lump that forms at the front of the
neck it's basically the corner of the
larynx aka the voice box closing out a
bit the purpose of the voice box is to
protect the vocal chords meaning is to
be kind of weird if evolution only
gifted that luxury to men yes sexist
kicks in during puberty when a voice
drops and one of girls doesn't the big
question now is do we have to start
calling it Adam and Eve's Apple probably
not number nine the misconception
wouldn't don't get erection fascinating
truth they do well kind of but guys
erections are an inevitable and
sometimes embarrassing fact of life
never embarrassing something women don't
have to be worried about don't be fooled
though just because women aren't waking
up with an awkward bulge in their pajama
bottoms it doesn't mean that they don't
get erections to the clitoris and organ
of female sexual pleasure is actually
surprisingly similar to a penis it has
hands and even a foreskin no hood really
is a small penis
you also have erectile tissue in your
nose so when you're excited your nose
actually swells a couple of millimeters
this also occurs fascinating adrenaline
meaning that the joke about Alliance
nose growing is not entirely false
whoa I knew ancient Egyptian women for
example used to remove hair using pumice
stones or Flint ouch
I think that's smart dermatology queried
3316 women and their preferences for
bikini area grooming and it's on the
outside rather than the inside sure you
have to have a baby always be mother to
sex at least twice a week 82% of 35 to
39 year old women conceived within a
year Wow
of 27 to 35 year olds conceived Wow is
tiny showing that age isn't as much of a
factor as it was once assumed what's
more medical advances are helping women
to conceive at much later point in their
life she gave birth to twin boys when
she was 66 years
Wow good for her six the misconception
women have smaller black king women pee
all the time
in 2005 the Journal of Urology asked a
group of men and women to keep urinary
Diaries of their fluid intake and who
would agree doctored that while that men
drank more water the women need to pee
more often many people assume that this
is because women have a smaller platter
or that their muscles are weaker and
less able to hold it in that's rubbish
it's the same size and strength as a man
it's just located in a place where
eventually in a female body there needs
to be room for bonus organs like the
uterus I'm sorry
misconception a being with my vagina it
was even the topic of a whole story
nineteen Netflix's orange is the new
black basically in between the vagina
and the clitoris is a separate hole the
urethra its entire purpose is to conduct
urine from that's why I like to link
outside the body the vagina on the other
hand never passes any urine through it
just fun sex things and babies from
their sexual organ women must - that's
probably thanks to how in a
America only 22 states actually required
public schools to teach sex education
that's insane 80% of US schools allow
parents to exclude their children from
such lessons
Wow understandings number four the
misconception women been essentially
have a penis the concept of female
ejaculation if what guys doing you're a
the source of quite a lot of confusion
women's health writer Rebecca choker
described the phenomenon as one of the
most hotly debated questions in modern
sexology women's squirting such a
controversial topic that it was even
banned from being shown in British porn
films in 2000 because it doesn't happen
to every woman 35 percent of women have
ever experienced the gushing of fluid
during an orgasm colleges disagree on
whether the liquid produced can be
classed as ejaculate for some women
there is no difference in the chemicals
present in the fluid squirted of orgasm
and the urine meaning it's effectively
just that suppose for others it contains
no traces of prostatic specific antigen
which is what you'd find in male
ejaculate I'm calling it if that's
what's in the men's that's hotel account
number sorry we only saw a woman when
were periods income this is for
absolutely sure having sex with a woman
on her period doesn't magically
eliminate the possibility of conceiving
a child why any of those should invest
in a decent only when I have
synchronized when they spend a lot of
time around one another in 1999 studies
found that 80 percent of women believe
this myth to be true even today you're
likely to see it reference there's a
lazy storyline in sitcoms and films but
very incompletely bogus 763 days study
of Dogon women in West Africa who was
segregated into
Hutson thou know'st synchronicity at all
similarly is study of 186 women in China
we actually terribly choose the right to
answer this question that's why you get
surgery women have a symmetric breasts
it's most commonly due to different
volumes of breast tissue all variations
in skin elasticity if a woman has put on
or lost weight relatively quickly
alternatively it can even be the result
of a baby breastfeeding on one side more
than the other really men wrote a whole
thing about women however it's also a
myth that it's impossible for a mother
to breastfeed her adopted child through
a combination of hormone tablets and
using the breast pump doctors are able
to artificially stimulate lactation in a
woman
so she can feed her non-biological
that's so hard
number one the missing section a woman's
vagina becomes loose if she has a lot of
sex absolutely true
is just the muscle expand and contract
just as any other muscle would hmm
think about it the vagina stretch is a
ridiculous amount during childbirth so a
woman can push an actual human life
through but then within just six months
of delivery it will have returned to
about the same tightness as it was
before the birth tightness gentlemen
how well-endowed you think you are your
member is probably not going to be doing
that much permanent damage this idea of
the loose vagina was further debunked by
dr. Rachel Raymond of Indiana University
how do you argue that even when using a
tenfold magnification even a doctor
can't actually tell if a patient is a
virgin or not if a doctor can't tell
really
vagina should not really be an issue so
that was 10 misconceptions about the
female body
damn join this video head over to our
friends at bloom where they might map
evolution of Pyrrhic hair to history and
as always make sure you like subscribe
and ring the bell for notifications
wrong all those fake news spreads are
symmetrical every women after they give
birth loose vaginas swarming the street
let's take a buncha one with loose
vaginas take him to Houston it'll
swallow up the water
Wilson save the scene boom subscribe to
these guys first off there are some
fascinating things in here I what I got
from this video is that vaginas in a lot
of ways are a lot like penises yes
fascinating yeah like I didn't I of
course I know that in to some degree I
didn't realize just how much details and
and similarity they are at the same time
vagina seemed way more advanced it's
like our penis is noticeable when were
turned on it gets bigger if you're lucky
and and we pee out of that same thing
very simple women are like no we have
like divisions yeah it's like category
actually goes inside and it's like a
whole like tree of like really organ
like with within itself
wow this you can't see there's not just
like a little touch on the outside
nicely I have never been more sexually
turned on in my life after knowing how
the clitoris works can you tell by my
nose
that's such a fast Olli test that out
like I think someone's turned on I just
look at their nose see if it expands I'm
gonna be very self-conscious about that
I feel like my nose like flutters now
then if I do that hey so the pubic hair
thing yeah
oh good I've been I had been reading
about that because I was like debating
like would would do i or don't I do well
your donut you know get her but it turns
out I've actually read this that if you
shave it too much it becomes dry and
scrotal really what about laser hair
removal I don't know but but apparently
it means the hair there to keep the skin
healthy and without it there it starts
to like shrivel up and dry and you have
to actively like moist resonated maybe I
should be more accepting of pubic hair
yes I as the handsome man I am do not
prefer pubic hair most of the time if I
love you I can usually let it slide if I
don't love you I would prefer shave but
maybe if a woman has pubic hair that's a
healthy sign it is a healthy sense of
healthy signs find she's read up on how
to take care of her own parts and then
she's taking proper care of them instead
of putting the health of her lady bits
behind which most important pleasing
whatever the guy in the situation is not
even care about her so you know what she
should do whatever she needs to do [ __ ]
that guy I gotta give an honest guy
thought about all this the first 9
misconceptions I was like yeah I know
those are misconceptions but the first
one was the only one about like a vagina
kidding loose how is the only one where
I was like I wonder that one's true
that's the only one in my life rather
than like does that actually happen oh
yeah it doesn't it doesn't get loosen um
you
can't tell if your girlfriend is cheated
on you based off of how her vagina feels
damn it yeah so if she were to go hook
up with a guy with a bigger schlong than
yours and then I won't ever know with
you no you wouldn't
I mean unless it was like me maybe if it
was with like a half an hour but in this
very short window you might be able to
tell does the same fight with them I
don't know we have to watch a video
about how well I should stop doing these
daily vagina inspections on my ladies I
mean if she come back to the channel
[Music]
people not come back women have a
ticking biological clock I thought there
was some scientific fact I mean the
66-year woman had to have some like arts
and my artificial stuff done to her
though in order to conceive it you are
possibly the more money you have to
spend on IVF and vitamins and all kinds
of therapies but also believe it is past
35 now I could be wrong because you're
the old science but past 35 you have a
higher chance of having a child with
developmental disabilities really yeah
and that's not just for women actually
men past the age of the bleep 38 are
more likely to have a child with mental
health issues I got three more years
worst case scenario just bang a younger
chick no cuz your sperm still gets old I
know and I'm just like so I can live a
sex-free life until I'm 37 then I'll
settle down and hope within a week okay
all right Greg you do that is that
realistic goals Ken the woman who P the
P holes the P holes and the woman mm-hmm
what is that hole called urethra that's
what the urethra is yes and you have a
urethral tube it's just located
somewhere else because you have bonus
points in your body
we have bonus parts stupid men fallopian
- that's why women are really the
dominant sex yeah we get you guys to do
everything and we like I'm helpless yeah
so smart I didn't fully keep up with the
woman's squirting okay so one-third of
women's squirt and two-thirds don't and
those two-thirds want the world to think
that nobody squirts and then the
one-third that squirts is like how we do
yeah [ __ ] squirting feels [ __ ]
good
that's basically the thing about
squirting Airman's like no that's not
real I think in my entire life I can
think of two women who have who I've
never been sexually involved with but
have told me that they squirt interest
and they said it's a sensational feeling
very interesting yeah you go I what I
want you to take away from this story is
I've never been with a woman whose car I
think women have to figure out how to
make themselves yeah yeah other thing
that squirting is not an orgasm that
function of squirting and actually
having an orgasm are two different
things and so some people might squirt
and not have an orgasm oh yeah
and you can orgasm and never squirt so
just if you are a guy who's out there
and has made ladies squirt guess what
you still maybe didn't make them come to
worry about that fact oh if they can't
hold dinner periods I can't believe
there were people who were like we gotta
get people together and try to find out
if their periods actually why are you
taking the time to find this if I had to
go in a menstruation Hut every time I
got my period I'm pretty sure I would
hold it in my period I have also been
that the dumb mind that has thought that
if you're on your period that's like a
birth control but apparently doesn't
always work that's why I only sleep with
a girl when she's on her period
with the lights off jokes people just
jokes Cappy true facts about your life
you know please still be willing to come
back on the show
alright well guys this has been the
daily sex show with Kat Alvarado and
Greg Alba we have changed a channel from
talking about films to sex topics and
according to the new YouTube guidelines
talking about sex is perfectly okay
that's what ad revenue looks for is
who's talking about sex I've learned
about women there's more to you than
meets the eye
yep there is yeah if brains and more
lots of parts it's it it really is
that's that might be the explanation men
are simple they got one thing to do at
all and it's all on display you like
women complicated mess down there
all right guys Cal Virata comedy the cat
over auto and Twitter and Instagram
follow me patreon.com slash the real
rejects become a picture on injected a
goodbye